[Music]
i think that girls don't get a fair
representation in these sports
it is very very important to me to show
that females can do as well or even
better than men
this great big story was made possible
by
[Music]
some estimates say online gaming traffic
will increase 7-fold by 2020
in the male-dominated field of esports
team asterix has been a pioneer giving
women a chance to compete and prove
themselves against their male
counterparts
my name is tammy
i go by the nickname furry fish and i'm
the team owner and manager of asterisk
asterisk is a female organization and we
are all gamers we formed in 2004 we were
the first dota team that was female to
be formed in the world
my name is kimberlyn
and i'm a dota 2 player in team
masteries dota is a team multiplayer
game it's a game of strategy
reactions and teamwork
economy when smoke it runs smoke and
kill the tinker now
the thinker i thought you forged
friendships that you you have never
expected yourself to make we want to be
a figure that female gamers will look up
to and we want to be able to empower
them to have the courage to move out
their comfort zone
we are seen as role models
not just
gamers
one of the long term goals of esther is
to groom up female gamers and to get
more female gamers interested in
competitive esports so that one day we
might have
a top female gamer or top female team
competing at the highest level
[Music]
you